all right the criminal conviction of
Harvey Weinstein is a milestone for the
me2 movement Weinstein faces up to 29
years in prison
after a New York jury found him guilty
of a first-degree criminal sexual act
and third degree rape on Monday the
verdict comes nearly two and a half
years after New York Times investigative
reporter Jody Cantor Cantor and Megan
tui broke the story of Weinstein sexual
assault allegations it helped ignite of
course the me2 movement and around 100
women came forward accusing Weinstein of
sexual misconduct and assault
Jody Cantor is CBS News culture and
gender contributor Jody good morning
what do you think this verdict means for
the me2 movement you know we've talked
about Harvey Weinstein many times at
this table for the first time we can sit
here and say he's a rapist he's a
convicted rapist the significance of
that is enormous and also what people
may not realize is that the importance
of this goes beyond the symbolism of
seeing him go off to jail this was a
longshot case case when you had over I
know there were two women but you kept
hearing over a hundred women I know it's
only two women were at the basis of
these charges despite all of these other
allegations it was tricky they both had
consensual sex with him after the
attacks now that happens in real life
all the time experts say but juries are
often not willing to convict they say oh
it's too messy or I don't believe so
what do we say that this has the
potential to reshape how sex crimes are
prosecuted whose voices are heard and it
may be an indication now we're in New
York City but it may be an indication
that juries are shifting yeah what does
what they'll believe jury was trying to
send here well I think that they
believed women either that the
overwhelming messages that they believe
the women and it was a rejection of Don
or a to know Harvey Weinstein's lawyer
and the arguments that she made she
could have argued this case on narrow
kind of surgical grounds well you know I
know I've not everybody's crazy about
him but let me tell you the facts she
did some of that but she made a much
broader argument she said this is a
the me2 case going too far she tried to
paint the women as the manipulators and
Harvey Weinstein as the victim and the
jury rejected that she was making these
really big cultural statements about how
this goes it's an overcorrection women
can't be women men can't be men but you
know one of the first women to come
forward in fact the first actress to
come forward Ashley Judd what was her
reaction to the verdict so a few minutes
after we got the decision I called hash
Li and I told her the news myself and
she paused and took it in and she said
this is how it's supposed to be this is
how it's supposed to be and then she
said something else what she said she
still craved from him was an apology and
an understanding of the pain he's caused
and that's exactly what he did not say
you know he stood there after the
verdict was announced he was very still
and then he said that I'm innocent
so how can you get an apology from
someone who doesn't believe that they've
done anything wrong I don't I don't I
mean I I'm not sure that's coming but
what this verdict I think does provide
is some resolution the Harvey Weinstein
story now has an ending yes I don't know
if it's the final ending he's still
going to be tried in LA his lawyers say
they may appeal this decision but right
now he appears he's at Bellevue Hospital
he appears to be on his way to Rikers
Island
he was remanded he was sent to jail
before sentencing nominee I've just been
free exactly to doing and so I think we
can say this even at this contentious
time even though me too is controversial
this story has come is beginning to come
to a close so do you you broke it this
story in 2017 and spent a lot of time on
it when you heard that verdict what did
it mean to you I always was focused on
the journalism and I was focused on
doing my job as a journalism which by
the way involves being fair to Harvey
Weinstein as well and Megan and I were
always operating even you know part of
the reason we wrote our book which we
called she said
to represent you know this idea of the
women's voices we knew the book had to
stand no matter whether he was convicted
or not we said journalism may be the
only form of accountability
he faces but you know I was in that
courtroom during the trial and I can't
tell you what a solemn exercise in
democracy it did feel like it felt like
those twelve anonymous Manhattan jurors
were really listening to every word and
really thinking this over and they had
to go into that room and not just decide
sort of clear matters of you know this
fact in that fact they had to talk about
issues of sex and power and consent and
this is what they came away with and
remember that a jury decision has to be
unanimous so I would just say the moment
was the moment was extremely meaningful
when we heard the news but then I think
it's in the last two days when I see it
reflected through the eyes of other
people that's when it really sinks them
you know do you think other witnesses
will want to come forward now it's a
fascinating question people may feel
that you know he's behind bars or soon
will be now I feel I can tell my story
I'm less afraid of reprisal and what
we've all what we've also seen
throughout this process is that
accountability drives more women coming
forward because you're not gonna want to
come forward if you don't think anything
is going to happen even if in the end of
sorts for Harvey Weinstein it could be a
beginning for many other cases exactly
right Jodie Jodie canter and we
mentioned the book she said which you
wrote with Megan to II highly recommend
this book by the way it's profound on
sale wherever books are sold